[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make the smooth segway
to wright thompson espn senior writer
the new book is papi land
a story of family fine bourbon and
things that last available beginning
today online and wherever books are sold
and a reason to drink bourbon for the
last four years while writing this book
well done right thompson how are you
buddy i'm doing great man
all right so the idea is hatched how
when where why you know at first it was
like maybe if i wrote a book about this
guy i could get some of this stuff
uh but it turns out they're like i kept
waiting to be shown like the mystery
supply but it doesn't exist it's so rare
that
the van winkles themselves barely have
it and
i just started going up there and
hanging out with them and i wasn't sure
what the book was going to be
and i'm sure you've experienced this the
conversations i was having about
you know he was going through a cancer
fight i just uh
had our first child and the
conversations we were having about his
father and my father
and the kind of parent i wanted to be
those
felt as much of the part of the story of
the whiskey as the whiskey itself and
and so the book was born it's a it's
sort of a winding together of the
history of the van winkle brand
and of kentucky bourbon with you know
like
my wife read it for the first time and i
was trying to tell her my grand literary
theory for it and she was like oh you
wrote eat pray love for dad
i was like damn it like that's not
don't tell anyone that you're gonna kill
my any street cred i had is
gone uh but uh it really is an
exploration of inheritance
and of you know the things that the
things we inherit from our fathers and
the things we want to pass on
to our children when did papi become
something bigger than just a bourbon you
know in 1997
it got this famous 99 score
and i don't even really know how those
things are rated but people went nuts
for it
and for years julian van winkle who
makes it
had just been going deeper and deeper
into debt to keep this thing alive
the short story is his grandfather pappy
van winkle
started the stitzel weller distillery
and then julian's father
lost it and so julian had spent his
whole life
just hanging on by his fingernails in
the whiskey business
to the point that this year he is
finally paying off the last of those
loans
so 2021 will be the first year in the
black oh wow
like that's how long it took and so they
got this score
and all of a sudden people went crazy
for it and everyone realized what
a small group of aficionados had always
known which was
this was the best stuff in a bottle in
the world and now i mean as you know as
that guy was just saying
it's almost impossible to find i mean
i'm raffling off nine bottles of it this
week
at book events and like people are
buying
10 tick like it's the response to those
raffle tickets
is pretty astonishing also when you're
talking to pappy
people think that he's the one that
jacks up the prices on the secondary
market
and he's not i don't know what a regular
let's say a 23
year aged bottle of papi what would that
go for what's a regular price for that
and then the secondary
it should be 270 to 300 and the
secondary market is
starts at three grand and just keeps
going up i mean it's really
crazy and julian will tell you no
bourbon is worth 30
000 you know i mean it's like
you know it's a it's a stretch at 300.
so it was pretty interesting to be
inside that and uh and
see them sort of deal with people who
think they're getting rich when they're
not
why kentucky why is kentucky the the
home of bourbon
you know american whiskey started it was
rye whiskey in new york state
and then in pennsylvania and then uh you
know the big
alexander hamilton george washington
fight over the whiskey tax was really
i mean the seeds of the 2020 election
were planted
then and the whiskey tax was designed by
someone who lived in a city
who sort of thought it was a syntax and
george washington understood that
making whiskey was how farmers who lived
way out in the middle of nowhere
kept their crops from rotting and so all
those people migrated from pennsylvania
down to kentucky because there was a
time when kentucky was the montana of
america
it was the wild frontier and so all of
those farmers
moved from new york to pennsylvania and
then down to kentucky
how would you describe that first taste
of pappy van winkle for those who
probably will never get that opportunity
you know even when they before the taste
i mean even when they pour it
in the glass and i'm not one of those
wine guys who can
you know like i'm not you know i don't
know how to do that so this is a pretty
amateur opinion
but just looking at it going in the
glass the viscosity of it is different i
mean i write about this a lot in papi
land
just watching people have it
do you know what i mean like the bucket
list aspect of it
you can tell when it's poured that it's
not the crap you were drinking in
college
can you take tours of of papi land
you can you can go to the buffalo trace
distillery it's actually really cool
uh i would not recommend doing it after
a night of hard drinking i took a
friend's bachelor party there one time
and you step out of the car man and it
is
overpowering smell of whiskey uh-huh but
no the tours are fabulous it's the
buffalo trace distillery
you sort of come down a hill it's like a
time machine i mean
you know so much of bourbon and the
people who love it is associated with
nostalgia i read somewhere recently
nostalgia comes from the greek words for
home and pain
and that sort of feels perfect when you
think about a glass of bourbon and
remembering your father or uh you know a
toast to people who are no longer here
and you know exploring why bourbon means
that thing to us is a big part of the
book
is there bourbon snobbery did you uh
encounter that
you know it's interesting there's so
much bourbon snobbery
uh and i was sort of making fun of him
and julian i mean
julian shut me down pretty good because
he was just like
hey man who are you to tell somebody how
to enjoy something
if the thing they like about it is being
a purist about it
then like live and let live man uh
and i learned from that actually i mean
i spent a lot of time around julian
and he's a pretty remarkable guy
and you know if i have a business
decision in the future or a family thing
he's somebody i would call
sort of like a father figure you know i
lost my father young and i think a lot
of people that that happens to
spend a lot of time trying to replace
that and looking for people who serve
that role in their lives
and so you know very early on i knew i
didn't just want to write the history of
van winkle i wanted to write about the
four years i spent with julian
because of that very reason because the
most interesting parts to me
were just riding shotgun with him and
hearing how he thought about things
yeah it presents itself is it it's about
bourbon but it's not about bourbon it's
it's about
lives it's about families it's about
fathers it's about sharing a moment
there you have
thoroughbred racing that's also
intertwined in this as well so there's
you know it's typical wright thompson
that you've got different layers going
on and
and i really enjoyed it was a a quick
read an easy read a great read it's
called papi land
the story of family fine bourbon and
things that last available beginning
today both online and wherever books
are sold are you going to the masters
you know i was going to the masters and
then i had
a two-week early daughter friday
so i am uh i am no longer going to the
masters
uh i am instead dealing with the utter
chaos in my house of the arrival of
louise thompson
so you got two under the age of two
two under the age of three so i need the
pappy van winkle
your wife might have needed that at
childbirth
instead of those jello cubes you would
just had bourbon cues
that's what i really i dropped the ball
on that dan i and
you know it's going to be so strange
with no patrons there and
the masters in november uh
it's still going to look the same
probably sound the same to a certain
degree except for the patrons but
i was surprised they didn't try to
incorporate any kind of
group there or give people an
opportunity you'd never get a chance to
go there
i think there's nobody gonna be there
that ambiance is really what separates
it from every other tournament
it's going to be really strange you know
uh espn had the
uh the i'm sure you know tim horgan and
bluefoot but like the guys who do all
those
bumps and teases they were just there a
week ago
and i was sort of expecting the place to
look different because it was fall yeah
and he called the first day was like
this is so weird
i don't know what they've done these
guys are miracle workers the course
looks
exactly like it would look in april i
mean like
these guys like seasons have no dominion
over whoever's running that golf course
is pretty remarkable we had a contest
that was uh
well you had a contest that you
incorporated our show and you
invited our listeners to write who they
would have
well give us the context of it and then
uh if you want to paraphrase the winning
letter
yeah man we were talking a couple of
months ago and
uh i just sort of said look tell me who
you would drink a bottle of pappy with
and why because i feel like that
question gets at the heart of what the
book is about which is
about community and friendship and loss
and regret
and longing and home and
i don't know man you do these things and
i expect you to get a couple of them and
i mean one of the things i mean you know
this very well and todd knows this
but the people listen to your show it's
a real community of people
and uh they're loyal uh they they love
it
and i certainly didn't realize that
until these results
these letters started pouring in and
like my wife and i would sit there and
read them and everyone was more moving
than the one that came before
i was like i don't know how i'm gonna
pick and ultimately
i got one today is the marine corps
birthday uh which is a big deal in the
marine corps
and uh i got a letter from a uh i don't
want to call him a former marine because
they get really upset about that
like i've done that in print and you
will only do that once because the
emails start
flooding in and so but he is a retire
he i don't know what he's not a marine
corps officer he's not active
correct okay and uh but he uh told me
that his name is ted hubbard
and he told me that he wanted to drink a
bottle
of pappy with the father of one of his
marines who was killed in afghanistan
and he sent me this picture of he and
three of his marines
including seth sharp who was killed in
action
as they're leaving on the mission from
which seth wouldn't return
he makes the hair stand up on my arms
and uh he said he wanted to drink this
bottle with seth's father rick
and i just thought that like that
instinct and impulse
flows through the very heart of
everything the book is trying to be
and so we sent him a bottle he's got it
right now
and uh i sort of feel like i mean jokes
aside man
anything else that happens from this is
gravy like
to be able to send one of these things
and have it serve its true purpose i
mean julian is over the moon at it
because as opposed to someone collecting
it and getting dust in a cabinet like a
trophy
this is going to be someone you know
using it for its purpose in the world
and it's just it really does say
something about the community of people
on the show
because i was stunned at the response
i mean a lot of people like i don't know
how many people listen to this dan but
uh uh it's a lot cause i was stunned at
the response
yeah i'd keep getting these updates from
right you'd be like they're not stopping
like
we're getting more letters oh it's so
hard to pick a winner and then i went
great i i was glad that my audience
responded to something that i thought
was
really important uh next sports story
you're working on
i have an archie manning profile coming
out on espn that i feel like is
for someone who's been written about as
much as archie manning i feel like this
is probably 8 000 new words about archie
manning
so i'm pretty excited about that it
feels wholly new
and uh man we are all masters all the
time i was up
last night recording voiceovers uh i was
talking about silence
that's the we're leading into it dan
uh well done as always great to talk to
you again
what's your next book man i got a couple
of things i'm kicking around uh
we actually uh um you're gonna do the
history of coors light is that what you
said
well i would think i was gonna do the
history of busch light because
here no do you have wait you don't want
to tell me is this something you want to
tell me
i have yeah i have a couple of things
i'm kicking around i'm also hoping
uh that the dan patrick audience buys so
many of these books that i get to go
back to penguin and like make them
triple their money
so yeah so you are here by deputized
congrats on daughter number two thank
you so much man
i'm really really excited now when you
get to your third daughter
then contact me and then i'll help you
oh you have three yes all right
all right i'm not joking like i have
lots of questions how old are they
they are in their 20s so
is everybody out of the house they never
leave
they never leave yes that's good and bad
i like i like the idea of
like we have a little kid running around
here talking about her baby hista
and it's the cool like i'm over the moon
well i got a uh
a 22 year old who said i said what are
you going to do
when you graduate from school and she
said i'm thinking of staying at home
living at home until i'm 30. and i said
okay like i i don't i love having them
home and girls are the best
and and the the advice i always give to
people is
listen if you're a dad listen to your
daughters
you don't have to lecture you don't have
to do anything other than listen
because they'll tell you everything you
want to hear if they think
you're listening and not lecturing well
that's actually really good advice
uh i mean i'm uh and use that with your
wife as well by the way
just listen i've already screwed that up
and have burp
have bourbon on hand as well
yeah that's what i'm doing yeah like
exactly
uh good luck with the book right great
to talk to you as always buddy thank you
so much dan thanks
uh wright thompson espn senior writer
the new book happy land a story of
family fine bourbon and things that
last